this morning on the dish Chef Gavin
Cason his debut restaurant spoon and
stable is named for the horse stable
that occupied the space in the early
1900s along with Cason's affinity for
making off with spoons from restaurants
he's dined in it's a habit on display at
the restaurant which he picked up to
memorialize special meals Cason's
Hospitality Group now includes two more
restaurants local bakeries and a
catering business that serves some of
the local sports teams but the project
that's closest to home for Cason is just
that a self-published cookbook we
traveled to the chef's Hometown to taste
it all
[Music]
at spoon and stable in Downtown
Minneapolis it's a little different than
cooking for my kids chef Gavin Cason
exquisitely pairs his expertise in
French cuisine no fire yet with Midwest
seasonality Along on one Brussels and
sensibilities and so the chips that we
serve with this
are these really great
Soca chips case in point Cason's bison
tartar is that great
so we've had that on since we opened
which has just been a really fun dish
Cason knows the Midwest palette because
he shares it spoon and stable is the
Native Son's triumphant return after an
acclaimed run at Danielle's Cafe ballude
in New York where he earned a James
Beard award for Rising Star Chef all
right so pasta course so it's a
caramelly pasta stuffed with celery root
lots of lemon zest hazelnuts fried
Rosemary and pecorino Romano
enjoy enjoy he'd earn a second Beard
award for best chef Midwest at spoon and
stable which instantly upped the Twin
Cities culinary game so duck breast case
in dry ages his duck for 10 days and
serves it with long greens Hoisin puree
and Shinko pear enjoy thank you for the
happy dance it was kind of that was
after a honey and cream cake for dessert
we dished about the question Cason says
he's asked most often do I cook at home
so a lot I cook a lot at home even
though you spend the bulk of your
evening here that's still enjoyable so
different you know here it's
full Chef white apron right formality in
a way discipline in every sense of the
word at home it's
Freedom peace and just Joy gotta Cube
your butter
here he gets to cook for himself his
family okay I know and best friend Rosie
who eagerly serves as a taste tester I'm
going to kind of show you how I cook
when I'm at home two and a half years
ago when Cason and his diners were stuck
at home he began to cook for them
remotely hey everyone welcome to GK at
home hosting a series of online cooking
classes here's the deal and we did a
little over 150 people on that first
class the second class there's 300
people the third class there's 600
people the fourth class there's over a
thousand people butcher the chicken go
slowly
but we could cook together we could
laugh together we could like just escape
from what was outside and what was the
distraction and focus on just this
nourishment and this idea of restoring
our souls through the power of food by
the end Cason had cataloged roughly 80
recipes and as a result we have sort of
this diamond that came from it he mined
the results for his first cookbook aptly
titled at home Cason divides the book by
the Four Seasons this is fantastic just
your normal afternoon spread right well
casual spread
for us Cason whipped up a taste from
each crispy chicken thighs with
vegetables and Endive salad for the fall
pulled pork tacos for summer for winter
time Cavatelli pasta with squash and
Brussels sprouts and his grandmother
Dorothy's pot roast which she made for
us all the time the key for Grandma
Dorothy's pyros which is in the book is
that she uses rutabaga as part of the
vegetables so it's not a potato starch
okay so it slowly thickens the sauce a
little bit and it also makes it a little
bit sweet and this is also one of the
most popular dishes it's good and stable
really it's like
it's so nostalgic for me do you have a
favorite recipe that's in the book is
that I mean obviously hers
have a special place in your heart what
makes me feel good about the book
honestly is that like everything that's
in it I I have cooked at home and I
still cook it at home Cason shares those
meals right here with some of his
favorite dining companions wife Linda
Sons Emile Julius and Crosby and of
course Rosie by the way Rosie wants more
the dog the dog has been the star of the
day I mean she wants more Rosie wants
Rosie wants everything she can have she
knows she knows the jam
almost as hard for me to resist
dessert from the spring section
sunbuckle cookies another recipe from
Grandma Dorothy so this was the first
thing that I made with her when I was
seven this was sort of like the Epiphany
dish for me this is why we have you as
yeah yeah Cason says that simple cookie
is what sparked his interest in
Hospitality I was probably the only
grandson in the kitchen with her uh
cooking with her all the time and baking
and I just remember everybody stopping
and running inside and having this
incredible amount of joy and excitement
and I thought to myself like seven
ingredients did that and it was a really
really pivotal moment of my life I knew
then subconsciously that I wanted to do
something in service for others the rest
of my life a career that started at age
15 making Subway sandwiches has allowed
Cason to feed others while nourishing
his own soul from prestigious kitchens
in Europe and New York to his own now in
Minneapolis true what did your
grandmother think
she was always Blown Away with the fact
that the cookies got me to this point of
like now I love to cook it just really
warmed her heart always to know that
food which is what she taught me really
gave me a spirit of my life that love of
food has any of that changed for you now
working in the industry as long as you
have no no I love it so much
it's just so great to be able to cook
for people and to serve people whether
it's at the restaurant or here on us on
Sunday yeah the only difference here is
there's just less there's a little bit
less stress of putting out 200 plates
you know I got to put out six plates of
food it's fun because
for for the boys they'll you know I mean
they'll be downstairs playing with their
friends and come up and it's like you
know a spread on the table they're like
yeah this is this is normal everybody's
coming to the kitchen right everyone's
yeah exactly yeah that's true that's
okay I'm happy to do it
so a chef did send the sunbuckle cookies
weather got in the way so I apologize
but Chef take a look you're not the only
one who can take spoons I have a very
fond memory now of spoon and stable we
told you that's the reason he takes
these spoons one for each of us because
one day the two of you will get two
spoon and stable and you will have a
taste of Chef Cason's wonderful food
there really is special really is
delicious and Chef I see why you kind of
keep the spoons to the side because you
know people like me are going to take
them too look at that can we go on GoPro
dog cam I know I love right
Barlow
getting Rosy